pion autre question peut-on vraiment
s'opposer à macron surtout après l'aveu
de défaites sur le code du travail
aveux signés jean luc mélenchon depuis
athènes le salut de la catalogne est il
à bruxelles
officiellement non mais si la commission
n'était pas un peu hypocrite dans cette
affaire et si une catalogne indépendante
ne finirai pas par faire les affaires de
la commission de bruxelles
nous voulons de la culture pas du
harcèlement mode horde des féministes
contre l'hommage rendu par la
cinémathèque de paris à romane paulin ce
qui est ce
outrancier est ce justifié et bien vous
réagissez dans le player du figaro.fr
c'est-à-dire dans l'écran dans lequel
vous voyez cette émission vous posez vos
questions également sur la page facebook
du figaro et on déposera à nos invités
anne fulda bonsoir alors porté au figaro
et auteur du best seller consacré aux
entre guillemets dragueur de vieux c'est
pas moi
la formule n'est pas de moi le dragueur
de vieux le plus célèbre de france
emmanuel macron un jeune homme si
parfait 7 aux éditions plon
daniel bilalian bonsoir vous avez été
ancien vous avez été directeur des
sports de france télévisions et
présentateur du jt de france 2 on
recommande votre dernier livre les
évadés
on recommande aussi les nouveaux enfants
du siècle d'alexandre de vécu au
journaliste au service débat opinion du
figaro est en charge de figaro boxe jean
daniel lévy bonsoir directeur du
département politique et opinion
d'harris interactive et éditorialiste à
l'excellente chaîne parlementaire lcp
on s'attendait à une reculade un
renoncement un de plus
un refus de la sélection edouard
philippe a tranché finalement à sa
manière il n'y aura pas de sélection
alors question le premier ministre at il
eu peur on l'écouté
ça arrive
parce que vous proposons aux étudiants
et aux lycéens français l'objectif ça
n'est pas que l'université disent non va
la refaire les gars font peut-être la
rentrée en scène et dans certains cas
elle dira oui si si quoi si le candidat
accepte un parcours adapté qui lui
permet justement de réussir dans la
filière climatologiques alors voir
philippe a dit au début de cette de
cette séquence 1 s'excuse pour les
petits problèmes de sons qu'il n'avait
pas eu peur du mot sélections alexandre
ii vecchio c'est pas si mal ce qu'a
proposé aujourd'hui edouard philippe
on pouvait voir le verre à moitié vide
ou à moitié plein ça c'est ma conso
normes non appel point de vue non mais
la réalité c'est que c'est que malgré
tout on en finit avec l'absurde tirage
au sort qui avait été proposé par najat
vallaud belkacem il ya quelques il ya
des bonnes choses à prendre dans cette
proposition dans les propositions de
fait par le gouvernement
par exemple celle d'un de deux
professeurs principaux au lycée parce
que je crois que c'est là aussi que
l'orientation se fait et qui peut y
avoir des départs pour gâcher dans
certains lycées ou où finalement les
professeurs ne détectent pas les les
bronzés l'aller après on peut voir quand
même le verre à moitié à moitié vide
puisque effectivement je pense qu'il
aurait sans doute fallu aller plus loin
on sait que à l'université il ya tout un
tas de filière je pense aux filières de
sociologie par exemple ou de psycho où
il ya un nombre d'élèves très très très
très important et les débouchés
professionnels sont très faibles donc je
pense qu'il aurait fallu une réforme
structurelle créer des filières un plus
sélectives et des filières et réfléchir
aux débouchés professionnels par la
suite plutôt que que ça et effectivement
il dit qu'il n'a pas eu peur du mot du
mot sélection mais je crois que que si
est tout même et que finalement une
perte sur les deux des deux tableaux
parce que verre à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein
ceux qui sont contre la sélection hiver
ont tout de même de la sélection et ce
qu'ils avaient envie d'une réforme plus
profonde plus structurelle trouvons
qu'il niera qu'il n'a pas été assez loin
anne fulda ils ont cédé au syndrome de
vaquer probablement mais bon c'est vrai
qu'il ya tout de même le point positif
comme la suppression de ce système atb
qui était un enfer pour les élèves les
parents d'élèves etc
donc ça sera remplacée par une autre
formule avery voilà bon ça c'est vrai
que je suis plutôt d'accord avec
l'alexandrie kyocera qu' il ya des
progrès c'est évident ça aurait pu aller
plus loin mais c'est sûr que là on sait
très bien que la jeunesse reste
inflammables mais finalement à force de
répéter on répète tous sans arrêt des
espèces de mantra comme ça ça fasse
finir dans la rue on a dit la même chose
pour la réforme du code du travail on a
vu que finalement ça s'est pas passé
donc vous anticipez oui mais oui mais
peut-être que la jeunesse c'est pareil
peut-être que si on lui avait proposé
une vraie réforme avec une vraie
sélection et des réformes structurelles
peut-être qu'elle ne serait pas
descendre alors oui en fait on sait pas
jean daniel et ses portes c'est
effectivement l'opinion est pourtant
favorable à une sélection d'après les
derniers sondages et y compris les
sondages qu'il a tout cas ça dépend ce
qu'on veut tailler des mots qui sont des
mots qui crée en général la tension le
fait que la pbv fonctionner la réponse
est non de manière extrêmement
majoritaire chez l'ensemble des français
avaient globalement sentiment qu'ils
avaient une injustice c'est à dire que
c'est pas forcément parce qu'on avait
fait une bonne scolarité c'est pas
forcément même parce qu'on avait eu des
bons résultats voire une mention au bac
qui pouvait y avoir la réputation en
cohérence avec la manière dont
l'étudiant où le lycéen avait pu se
comporter dans quelle est cette forme de
critiques de la part de la part des
français pour autant quand on regarde
les termes on sait qu'il ya des termes
qui suscite des tensions fortes et des
français globalement au sentiment que le
bac doit quand même être la première
entrée vers l'enseignement supérieur si
on a le sentiment que bahia du manière
au de l'autre pas la possibilité pour
tous les français notamment quelle que
soit leur catégorie sociale de pouvoir
accéder à l'enseignement supérieur il ya
une tension il peut y avoir un petit
vent des critiques fortes qui peuvent
être émis à l'égard des différents
gouvernements
il ya quand même une notion d'égalité
qui
dans la série française on voit peu elle
traverse de manière assez lettres
l'ensemble du regard à l'égard des
politiques publiques qui sont établis et
c'est lorsqu'on a le sentiment que ya
une rupture d'égalité ou une rupture
d'égalité des chances dans ce contexte
là il peut y avoir une rebuffade assez
fort de la part des français
daniel bilalian oui non je crois que la
première chose à voir de près c'est que
le niveau du bac qui était avant un
excellent niveau qui ne nécessitait
aucune sélection à l'entrée en
université n'est plus de ce niveau là
donc aujourd'hui ce qui se passe dans
les universités c'est que le niveau du
bac il a considérablement descendu
puisqu'on veut que tout le monde et le
bac on est à 80% de réussite
moi ce que je vois à lever le verre à
moitié plein comme disait notre ami
c'est effectivement qu'on a arrêté le
système de sélection anonyme un peu
comme le tiercé et tirage au sort le
tirage au sort mais en même temps
comment dirais-je finale finalement
l'étudiant l'étudiant il fera ce qu en
ce qu'il voudra il fera quand même ce
qu'il voudra parce qu'il y aura au début
une concertation entre les professeurs
de l'école dé du secondaire et des
universités mais finalement si le garçon
et ses parents ont envie qu'il continue
ville pourra il pourra qu'il pourra
continuer c'est les réformes à la
française ça va quoi ça me fait penser
en un mot c'est la réforme souvenez
quand on a voulu interdire les vitres
teintées dans les voitures à cause du
terrorisme
on a décidé que c'était 30 % 2
30 % seulement de teinture qui pouvait
être acceptée vous imaginez vous êtes
policiers dans les rues
vous allez voir vous avez une voiture en
disant vie dont vous avez 30 % ou pas
prendre pour cent voilà c'est à peu près
ça l'art et la la réforme de lignes
haute et olivier vial le président de
l'uni est avec nous en ligne on va
l'interroger dans une minute mais
d'abord j'aimerais qu'on fasse un détour
par les réseaux sociaux services auquel
travaillent dans lequel travaillent
valentin pilates au figaro.fr comment
valentin on a réagi à l'annoncé
d'edouard philippe celui dit alors
envoyé tout à l'heure à la question du
jour où quatre plus de 80% de nos
internautes se disent pour une sélection
à l'université alors une sélection oui
mais laquelle
du moins c'est la question qui se pose
sur deux pour les internautes et
notamment ceux du figaro alors
premièrement on à gabriel qui se dit
quand même satisfait de ce qui est
proposé par edouard philippe donc sur le
site internet figure il me dit enfin une
réforme intelligente dans le domaine
fini l'apb ridicule et ses tirages au
sort honteux fini aussi l'inscription
automatique et le droit à l'université
sans un minimum de sélection il ya
papangue également qui partage cette
satisfaction et en ai même fait
carrément plus gourmands il y aurait
aussi à faire une vraie sélection à
faire selon lui pour les deux dernières
années de scolarité avant le bac avant
d'orienter vers l'apprentissage ou
encore l'alternance souvent bien souvent
négligée on à philippe qui renchérit sur
le site internet toujours
enfin un peu de bon sens pour mettre fin
à ce processus de tirage au sort
absolument injuste est vraiment débile
nous précise-t-il
on a cause toujours sur twitter qui nous
dit qu'ils envoient un message en fait
aux étudiants les lycéens doivent
désormais savoir que l'accès à
l'université n'est pas un dû et certains
devront se mettre au boulot fous
note-t-il on à l'unef également sur
twitter qui lance une pétition contre
sélection de cette recette sélection
donc si la pétition contre la mise en
place de la sélection à l'entrée de
l'université nous dit l'unef lui ni
réagir a certainement juste après et
vale ou valve ou qui s'agace oui la
jeunesse s'agace sur les réseaux donc en
gros ce qui remplace le système ap élevé
maintenant c'est l'avis des profs et
c'est eux qui vont décider pour nos
voeux s'interroge-t-il
en fait c'est vraiment ça qui se dégage
c'est les internautes sur twitter ou sur
le stand du figaro les jeunes voient en
fait leur avenir passe entre leurs mains
il ne se sent plus
m en fait de cette décision par un pb où
les profs en fait prendre et limite les
décisions à leur place
alors olivier vial qui est le président
de l'unis l'union nationale inter
universitaire qui le syndicat des
étudiants de droite bonsoir comment vous
réagissez l'ajustement à ce que est ce
que vous venez d'entendre est-ce que
vous pensez que les étudiants sont
désormais dépossédés de leur avenir
universitaire en partie c'est vrai qu'on
fait une véritable occasion
on aurait pu avoir un vrai débat sur la
traduction est un vrai une réflexion
transparent pour on dise aux étudiants
bac elle bat il faut faire pour avoir
tout pour entrer dans quelle filière qui
permettait aux étudiants d'avoir
toujours la main il choisit rapidement
les la manière de fonctionner or
aujourd'hui on a créé parce qu'ils ont
peur d'une sélection ils ont créé un
vrai système bureaucratique avec plein
de commissions qui vont se succéder pour
au final ne même pas sélectionné
réellement les étudiants et donc on a
effectivement un gâchis humain et
financier que ça va coûter très très
cher pour finalement un résultat qui
fera très très mauvais olivier valent
pas vial parmi les annonces il ya le
rattachement des étudiants à la sécurité
sociale
jusqu'à présent c'était géré par des
mutuelles la mnef ou d'autres mutuelles
qui étaient proches de votre votre
syndicat comment vous réagissez à cet
assaut changement là aussi on
surveillait de près mais là encore une
demi mesure puisque finalement on
annonce que ont fait cadeau de
l'acception des droits d'inscription aux
étudiants sauf que dans le même temps on
leur prend un peu plus de la moitié de
la somme pour un fonds dont on ne sait
rien et dont on ne sait pas comment il
va être gérée et a priori il ya des
vraies inquiétudes sur des conflits
d'intérêts possibles parce qu' il serait
plus ou moins gérer comme les tels les
fonds de solidarité de la part des
associés et par des responsables
associatifs étudiants
donc elle tue on est une vraie un vrai
point de visite ans parce que on est
dans quelque chose ou on a eu vent
qu'une garantie le gouvernement nous dit
qui fait qui fait un cadeau aux
étudiants de 110 euros
et dans le même temps il remonte une il
y prend de l'autre main 120 euros dans
la poche des étudiants
donc là il ya une manip dont on ne voit
pas bien l'intérêt n'est qu'
effectivement bas il fallait faire
plaisir à au syndicat devenus
majoritaires la fage qui avait fait de
ce cheval de bataille un point de
négociation et donc c'est pour faire
plaisir à la fage quel club sans doute
la sélection bon froid on fera un débat
avec olivier vial sûr avec la avec la
fage fido faux et avec l'unef sur ces
questions là juste vous êtes bon un peu
négatif sur 7 sur ces annonces la fin de
la pub et quand même c'est pas mal non
oui sauf mais 5,8 beaucoup plus soutenu
et ça aurait pu être beaucoup plus
efficace puisque en fait aujourd'hui on
a par exemple 94 % des bacheliers
professionnels qui échoue à l'université
demain ils pourront toujours s'inscrire
à l'université
il aurait été beaucoup plus simple de le
redire quand on a un bac pro n'a pas
vocation à rentrer à l'université on a
vocation à faire d'autres filières ou à
trouver un emploi et donc au
gouvernement de l'amp est des systèmes
pour vous aider à trouver un emploi
or on n'a pas fait ça pour éviter le mot
sélection et donc les bacheliers pros
peuvent continuer à par le biais de
différentes commissions à rentrer à
l'université et au bout il y aura quand
même un échec et un échec massif
on est sur 94% des chèques en quatre ans
au lycée louis olivier vial il ya 2 500
ans la dernière question elle est posée
par daniel au final il n'y a plus de
place dans les facs
comment faire dit elle le problème de la
scène de selex de la sélection est il
vraiment le vrai problème
alors il ya effectivement une mauvaise
affectation des espions ce que comptait
pas faire l'année dernière il y avait
130 mille places non occupées dans les
universités une très mauvaise gestion
des ressources humaines et très mauvaise
gestion des places l'année dernière 130
mille places non occupées
donc on n'a pas un problème de locaux on
n'a pas un problème de moyens on a un
problème d'orientation des étudiants et
d'orientation des moyens et pendant très
longtemps on n'a pas voulu regarder
comment orienter les moyens et donc on a
créé des postes et des places dans des
filières qu'ils n'ont aucun débouché
donc ou que les étudiants bouder et là
c'est là le vrai point noir de cette
réforme c'est que cette réforme crée un
dispositif d'orientation en fin de
course
si un étudiant n'a aucun aucune
affectation il ya une commission
électorale qui va l'affectif dans des
filières où il ya de la place donc
l'orientation par défaut devient
finalement une orientation validée par
un recteur et ça c'est ce qui a plu
catastrophique parce que ce qu'il
fallait faire ferrer orienter les moyens
humains et financiers des universités
pour aller vers des filières qui roule à
venir faire des filières qui sont
demandées par les d'étudiants et par
réaffecter les étudiants dans les
filières où ils vont y aura de la place
à merci quand on fait ça on a
effectivement des élections qui vont se
retrouver le nez dans le bec dans l'eau
non blancs de chercher un emploi
merci beaucoup olivier vial on l'a vu
vous êtes critique ça vous fait au moins
un point commun avec vos frères ennemis
de l'unef sur cette question merci
d'avoir été en direct avec tous d'un
point de vue sur figaro live alexandre
devient trio je sais c'est quand même là
l'opposition elle est frontale
ouais j'ai juste avant pendant qu'on
fait la sélection elle existe et qui est
une vaste hypocrisie puisque il ya une
sélection pour les vers les filières
d'excellence vers les grandes écoles
vers les écoles de commerce qui
d'ailleurs c'est une sélection parfois
par l'argent quand on dit on a un
sentiment d'inégalité c'est la situation
actuelle qui est extrêmement
inégalitaire l'université elle est
gratuite mais la tendance à devenir une
espèce de poubelle où on déverse les
élèves
deux catégories modestes sans
s'intéresser à la suite de leur parcours
et on se dit qu'ils vont faire quelques
années d'une île assiettée pour pour
l'instant l'année seront pas dans les
statistiques du chômage donc je crois
que l'enjeu il est vraiment là à
transformer l'université en une filière
d'excellence accessible pour tout le
monde alors question c'est la question
qui est posée dans sur le site internet
du figaro sur lefigaro.fr faut-il un
examen d'entrée à l'université
daniel bilalian ben écoute et après tout
ce qu'on a dit oui en ce serait à mon
avis beaucoup plus simple ce que je
viens d'entendre trouve que ce serait
beaucoup plus simple mais alors là je
crois que ce serait là la révolution là
parce que les français sont toujours
d'accord pour les réformes
sauf si ça les concerne donc je pense
que une vraie sélection se serait
indispensable aujourd'hui étant donné je
reviens sur ce que dit tout à l'heure
étant donné aujourd'hui le niveau du
baccalauréat c'est ça l'essentiel avant
ça ne se posait pas ça ne se posait pas
ça se pose aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on s'inspire un peu plus de
ce qui se passe à l'étranger notamment
en allemagne où ils savent sens
101 rougir orienter ceux qui n'ont pas
le bac enfin l'équivalent du bac vers
une filière professionnelle mais c'est
vrai qu'en france malgré tous les
discours répétés année après année on
n'arrive pas vraiment à revaloriser 7 7
7 7 7 voilà et c'est dommage donc ça je
trouve que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudrait qu'on creuse et un examen de
sélection où et pourquoi pas il ya
quelque chose moi qui m'avait je
trouvais intéressant s'il avait été
proposée tout d'abord par edgar morin et
quelques temps c'est une année de
propédeutique bon ça coûterait beaucoup
d'argent mais que l'année après le bac
il ya une sorte de formation d'ouverture
de culture générale pour les pour les
étudiants pour c'est une espèce de mai
mais c'est quelque chose qui rend leur
dans l'est effectivement je pense serait
très très très important et enrichissant
pour les étudiants pour les pour les
lycéens j'aurai l'âge et si on pose la
question faut-il un examen d'entrée à
l'université ça va être ça va être une
levée de boucliers comme si c'est
absolument certain statut sur différents
aspects qu'on a pu appuyer vos tristes
et et qu'elle est est une émission qui
sont aujourd'hui assigné au collège au
lycée voire à l'université est-ce que
c'est préparer des individus à pouvoir
entrer sur le marché du travail ou est
ce que c'est former des citoyens et la
permettre de savoir le monde dans lequel
on évolue actuellement ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand vous interrogez
les français de manière générale il n'y
a pas forcément de lien intime entre ce
qu'on va apprendre aujourd'hui aux
étudiants ce qu'on va apprendre
aujourd'hui à la jeunesse et le fait
qu'il puisse y avoir soit un lien avec
une activité professionnelle direct soit
même un lien avec l'entreprise et quand
on compare effectivement avec les
modèles étrangers
le lien qui existe entre les études
supérieures voire même les processus
d'orientation qui peuvent arriver à des
âges qui sont beaucoup plus jeunes que
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui vont amener
vers soi une professionnalisation soit
des bacs professionnels soir vous
soi-même vers l'apprentissage de manière
bon ou l'alternance qui est beaucoup
plus développé qu'en france selon qui un
principe qui est un principe
pratiquement de citoyenneté et pas
uniquement de préparation à l'insertion
dans la vie active qui est aujourd'hui
les peuples et pas uniquement la part de
l'université mais la part de l'ensemble
du système lymphatique à
d'extraordinaires jeu
comme vient de le dire anne fulda il
faudrait une année de culture générale
après le bac c'est à dire après sept ans
de lycée il faudrait enfin une année où
on pratique la culture générale ça
commence à devenir un peu dramatique
quand même devra faire là pour gérard
surfer sur facebook il est nécessaire
d'accentuer l'orientation des jeunes
julie nous dit la sélection est
nécessaire pour faire le tri dans nos
universités relever le niveau
aujourd'hui beaucoup trop d'étudiants
art est en cours de route car ils sont
mal informés est-ce que ça c'est quelque
chose qui ressort justement un problème
de mauvaise orientation dans le à la fin
du à la fin du lycée pendant les études
est ce que il ya une expression dans
l'opinion et en particulier dans
l'opinion des jeunes français sur ce
défaut d'information sur l'oriental et
soit un défaut d'information souvent
défaut de valorisation c'est à dire que
d'une manière générale en fait lorsqu'on
se retrouve orienté à la fin de la
cinquième à la fin la troisième ou
éventuellement après la terminale
ça n'apparaît pas comme étant un schéma
de réussite qui apparaît comme étant
valorisé en tant que tel on parle
aujourd'hui effectivement des grandes
écoles on parle de l'université on parle
pas forcément de manière assez nette de
tous qui sont les filières
professionnalisantes même relativement
jeune et quand on compare là aussi par
exemple l'allemagne ont mené dans des
modèles qui sont des modèles de
représentation de mise en avant qui sont
extrêmement différents et qui font que
en plus de problèmes entre guillemets
d'information il ya peut-être apprendre
de valorisation de ce que peut être les
autres filières tu vas des filières
alternatives à celles qui conduisent
notamment à l'université et c'est un
mouvement que l'on voit après dans une
deuxième partie de la vie où il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui ont fait des
études supérieures et qui finalement se
reconvertissent dans des métiers plus
manuelle est ce que le gouvernement
craint une opposition dans les facs
c'est un petit peu la question qu'on se
pose cette après midi après l'annonce
les annonces d'edouard philippe et
surtout quand on voit ce qui se passe
sur face à emmanuel macron puisque la
question aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils aussi
va s'opposer à emmanuel macron hasard du
destin du calendrier
toutes ces annonces tous ces événements
surviennent 48 heures après la mort de
jacques sauvageot patron de l'unef en
mai 68
une page se tourne surtout qu'il est
rejoint dans la tombe par le dessinateur
de la rose au poing le logo du parti
socialiste
les symboles de la gauche disparaît ce
jusqu'au front social emmanuel macron à
gagner sur la loi travail ce n'est pas
moi qui vous le dis ce n'est pas lui non
plus mais ceux qui se sont apposés
opposé à lui précisément sur la loi
travail
je vous propose de les écouter pour
l'instant c'est lui quel point faut pas
chercher à le cacher parce que si on
vous raconte des histoires on n'est pas
crédible bon on peut espérer reprendre
le point et c'est clair que si la
jeunesse se met en mouvement et c'est
parti mais c'est pas le cas pour
l'instant macron avance parce qu'il n'ya
pas de la marque quel point c'est la
marque alpine il a marqué des points si
vous voulez mais parce que il n'y a pas
d'opposition suffisamment rassembler et
structuré face à lui
emmanuel macron doit jubiler quand il
entend ça d'antan dans les moments
d'abattement de janick meilleure chose
qu'on avait effectivement pour présenter
comme l'opposant numéro un et qui nous
avaient promis qu'ils auraient un
million de personnes qui défileraient
sur les champs elysées donc
effectivement on en n'est pas là
effectivement
on pensait après après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron et j'étais parmi les
premières à rappeler son score de
premier tour en disant n'oubliez pas
qu'il n'a que vingt quelques mannequins
des 24% des voix des français et que ce
n'est pas toute la france et que
obligatoire mans un moment se
distanciant jusque voilà et finalement
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation où on voit une opposition
qui semble anesthésie un front national
qu'on n'entend pas une droite qui ont
les républicains qui rend en voie de
recomposition le parti socialiste qu'on
entend qu à travers la voix de l'ancien
président françois hollande est ce que
ça d'ailleurs pas
est-ce que c'est pas d'ailleurs
justement sur sur hollande on renvoie
d'ailleurs à l'excellent dossier sur le
figaro à lire encore en kiosque
aujourd'hui et sur lefigaro.fr sur
l'impossible retraite de hollande est-ce
que l'ancien président à l'impopularité
record qui s'opposaient ce que c'est
même pas l'opposition rêvée pour macro
oui c'est sur quoi qu'il faut se méfier
parce qu'il peut il peut aussi tapé où
ça fait mal comme d'ailleurs
wauquiez dans son interview au journal
du dimanche la nappe est aussi où ça
faisait mal
on va on va reparler mais juste sur ce
plan là daniel bilalian
quand on voit justement ce qu'a dit
mélenchon ce que disait mon philippot
derrière on a envie de dire chapeau
l'artiste un maquereau mon bain pour
l'instant il n'a pas trouvé une réelle
opposition parce qu'il a il a agit sur
tous les tableaux comme il avait
toujours voulu faire ni de droite ni de
gauche et c'est vrai que le câble en
même temps à marcher
l'opposition ne trouve pas ses marques
dont mélenchon lui il a fait le camelot
pendant toute la campagne présidentielle
électorale pro stylo pour 100 francs il
y en a pas un qui écrit mais aujourd'hui
il paye ce qu'il a ce qu'il a fait je
veux dire pas grand mais exagéré quant à
wauquiez lui pareil il ya il est reparti
dans le dans un numéro pas possible
c'est à dire que il y a il est comme
alain juppé avec son identité heureuse
lui dimanche il nous a dit macron n'a
pas d'âme il a la haine de la probable
justement valait un programme c'est
parce que vous assistez daniel on va
l'écouter
laurent wauquiez il parle de start up
nation
il ne parle pas de nation française je
trouve parfois chez lui visiblement les
français elle ressemble très fortement
beaucoup de froideur
un vrai manque d'empathie
quand il va vers les français est au
fond une forme d'arrogance
les français attendent de la fermeté ils
attendent des convictions
ils attendent une vision du pays skis
emmanuel macron n'explique jamais ils
n'attendent pas un petit président
arrogant et capricieux qui dès qu'on ose
le contester hausse le ton et vous
demande de vous taire anglais accablé
par balles ça veut rien dire qu'est ce
que vous voulez moi je suis citoyen
français je vous requip moins de chômage
et cetera il me parle de la haine de la
province
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut rien
dire c'est du pipeau sac ça m'intéresse
pas ça m'a franchement ça m'intéresse
pas je n'y trouve pas il trouve pas
alors le seul le seul le seul moyen
qu'ils auraient d'intérêt c'est
peut-être un certain nombre d'électeurs
de droite c'est le problème sur
l'immigration et l'émigration pardon et
là ils l'abordent avec beaucoup de
de prudence mais pour l'instant il est
il est coincé parce que macron il fait
un peu le programme que qui aurait dû
faire la droite
économiquement il dans les autres sur
les derniers que c'est justement est-ce
que ça va le seul économie finance sur
le plan économique mais justement toile
et tous les autres champs restent
inexplorés donc il a maison d'aller la
nuit non mais je veux dire c'est sept
ans pourrait des mots dont les français
ce que c'est pour ça j'ai fait référence
à alain juppé l'identité heureuse mais
douze mois le jour j'ai entendu ça
millimes
d'où sort-il d'une sortie de leurs
employés c'est mon la paix et c'est pour
ça que macro il a raison il a raison de
parler de deux bords adresse jean slim
voilà il parle comme nous ces gens là ne
parle pas comme moi en tout cas
comme j'ai envie d'entendre pour les
français parlaient comme les français
parlent entre eux j'en ai à lévis
justement ce qui est intéressant c'est
que les lignes sur lesquelles en fait
laurent wauquiez peut intervenir
aujourd'hui sont assez limitées c'est à
dire que quand vous interrogez comme un
temps j'ai déjà de manière générale les
sympathisants de droite voire même les
électeurs de françois fillon
quand vouloir demander de juger la
politique des manuels macron il porte un
jugement qui est un jugement assez voire
très positive avec la perception que de
toute façon effectivement ils le jugent
aujourd'hui strictement mais surtout
l'appel ce curieux vient de dire daniel
bellaigue mais justement sur ces sur ces
concepts sur lesquels laurent wauquiez
attaques du même code il cherche à
changer la nature du débat et faire en
sorte que le jugement espère un peu
marshall aujourd'hui on voit le ciel
seul point sur lequel il peut y avoir
effectivement une insiste de la part de
l'électorat droite pourquoi parce que
ses électeurs
aujourd'hui vont considérer sur le fond
de la politique vienne et d'équations
entre ce qu'ils peuvent penser ce qui
est menée par le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron en revanche se son côté
personnel ou sur son côté gestion
autoritaire ou pas forcément en lien
avec les territoires
c'est un point sur lequel les personnes
qui habitent dans des zones rurales des
personnes qui me donne des zones
décentralisée peuvre la perception qu
eux-mêmes ne sont pas entièrement
entendu ce qui est intéressant c'est que
laurent wauquiez aujourd'hui s'il fait
ça il arrive à créer un débat qui est un
débat qui ne se posait pas préalable
alors daniel sait pas si pippo s'il fait
ça écoutez oui je comprends je veux dire
la petite ouverture cas laurent wauquiez
c'est de parler des territoires un peu
comme françois baron en effet dans une
interview récemment encore parler de la
de la france rurale et sa seul
désavantage de macron gérer c'est que
lui et son ils sont partis politiques ne
sont pas des gens de terrain
ce sont des gens qui sait qui était
derrière leurs ordinateurs qui sont
devenus députés par hasard et c'est des
gens qui ne
n'est ce pas le terrain qui ne
connaissent pas vous moi sur le terrain
parce que dans le village
l'épicerie a fermé la gendarmerie va
partir il ya plus de médecins ça ils
connaissent pas cette france là et là il
a raison là il peut il peut
effectivement laurent wauquiez trouvé de
l'adhésion dans le public je trouve
intéressante interview au journal du
dimanche
c'est qu'il va un peu sur le terrain des
manuels macron je pense que c'est il
joue une carte psychologie qui veulent
déstabiliser
il attaque justement en utilisant lui
qui est normalien alors qu'emmanuel
maquereau en rater normale en le
traitant de renvoyer miracle de bellamy
en parlant les autres ags le désert de
la météo et je pense qu'il pense comme
cela parce qu'effectivement c'est c'est
pas faux il
ils forcent le trait mais c'est pas faux
qu'il a un ego surdimensionné comme
d'ailleurs beaucoup de présidents
c'est pas faux qu'il est chatouilleux
sur ce sujet là qui n'a du mal à
supporter la critique donc je pense
qu'il essaie de le faire sortir de ses
gonds
parce par ce biais là en utilisant
d'ailleurs dans cette interview j'étais
frappé quand vous dites emmanuel macron
parle comme louis parfois ils parlent
comme nous et comme comme parler sarkozy
par exemple mais parfois il nous parle
des passions tristes nous parle de
littérature il ne parle pas toujours un
langage si si populaire que ça n'est pas
le soir son interview télévisée par
exemple c'était pas du tout donner parce
qu'il a il veut ni joue un peu là dessus
il essaie d'enfoncer aussi une porte sur
7 cet aspect psychologique
l'enfant du siècle n'a pas encore parlé
avec sa belle-fille oui c'est difficile
je veux faire la femme donne un peu de
tout ce qui a été dit moi je suis je ne
m'attendais pas cette hollandisme km/h
et désolé aujourd'hui c'est un peu le
cas je pense que que wauquiez a compris
effectivement qui devait s'adresser aux
classes populaires à ceux qui n'ont pas
été voter à la présidentielle voire à
ceux qui ont voté marine le pen est
effectivement à cette france qui n'est
pas la france des bobos de grandes
métropoles qui a qui a voté macro
maintenant est-ce que la corde
est-ce que la tactique ne se voit pas un
peu trop et est ce que justement il
arrive à parler suffisamment populaire
aussi si j'écoute daniel
bisaillon pas tout à fait encore mais en
tout cas je pense que c'est la bonne
direction tactique et idéologiques et de
free devient d'essayer et en plus ça
s'apprend auprès des journalistes et
auprès de l'opposition s'est là-aussi
wind et il est assez fort je pense parce
qu'il est dans une élection interne on
lui reproche d'être trop à droite mais
où les militants le son et c'est aussi
le manière de galvaniser les militants
et transgresse pour être ensuite attaqué
comme le faisait très bien nicolas
sarkozy pour souder finalement les
militants de droite derrière lui ensuite
il faudra qu'ils élargissent alexandre
j'aurais quand même que vous réagissiez
ce que d'une difficile et philippe
difficile de se poser un maquereau est
ce pour autant un problème alors que la
france a besoin de fermeté et de prise
de décision assumée mais oui ça ça des
mets pas d'ailleurs canal macron a signé
la loi antiterroriste qui entre en
vigueur
oui alors là on l'a vu ça faisait très
très poli le bureau je sais pas si ça
faisait décision assumée assuré on
aurait dit le politburo du parti
communiste
il suffit pas de dire qu'on fait les
plus grandes réformes jeudi le conseil
national de la résistance pour que ce
soit la réalité il a fait le plus gros
pot aérien depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale la plus grande réforme du
marché du travail depuis le cnr
je suis pas sûr que ça fonctionne parce
que la réalité des gens ne changent pas
forcément alors oui on a besoin de
décisions assuré mais celle de
maquereaux vont toujours dans le même
sens elle vaut toujours vert à cette
france qui a voté pour lui qui bénéficie
de la mondialisation donc vers plus de
dérégulation et il ya toujours pas le
mot protection dans son discours je
crois que la majorité des français ont
besoin de matériaux terrain il a parlé
un peu effectivement de d'immigration en
une phrase seulement les françaises ne
sont pas vus puis il a dit il faut
renvoyer les gens chez eux
or en l'état actuel du droit français et
du droit européen c'est impossible alors
je veux pas le décourager mais il va
falloir qu'il fasse des propositions
concrètes en ce sens sinon ça
fonctionnera pas les les migrants vont
continuer d'arriver les son papier vont
continuer d'être d'être là non je
voulais simplement dire
il ya un chercheur américain qui a fait
d'ailleurs j'ai l'habitude dans le
figaro un étude très intéressante sur
aujourd'hui il ya plus deux catégories
de gens dans le monde
les sommaires et les énumère et lui il
est plutôt partisan des aînés were ceux
qui peuvent travailler n'importe où dans
un open space
entre deux escales alors que nous les
sommes were on n'est pas contre le
progrès mais on a envie de travailler
chez nous et d'être chez nous et
d'appartenir à un pays juste and jouets
avoir votre avis notre confrère de
l'opinion jean dominique merchet vient
de publier un essai sur macro et
bonaparte dans lequel il ya beaucoup de
qualité d'abord parce qu'il rend hommage
à votre bio du président et l'autre
c'est qu'il pose une question et si le
pyramid macron ce n'est pas ma qu'on lui
même je pense qu'effectivement il ya un
petit
danger voilà bon mais que et je reviens
à ce que disait laurent wauquiez je
pense qu'il a c'est ça qui l'a compris
je pense qu'effectivement il ya parfois
une espèce d'enivrement
il y a bon c'est vrai qu'il réussit
c'est vrai que ce qu'il a dit à une
interview sur ce sur tf1 en cinq mois
voilà je les fais on ne croyait pas tous
à tous que tout ce que j'avais annoncé
je les fais ça c'est vrai donc donc il a
quelques raisons d'être satisfait le
danger c'est effectivement la griserie
et c'est effectivement cette perception
d'une d'une forme de morgue et
d'arrogance de france d'en haut je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui demeure
malgré tout c'est un peu ça tuberie ce
qui a déclenché la chute de sa
popularité cet été j'en ai mais c'est le
passé le moment où alors que les débuts
a été considéré comme étant plutôt
réussi même s'il est parfois des
instruments de communication qui était
assez gros et qui était perçu comme
étant gros remontée du command car la
sortie est la remontée des
champs-elysées à pied ou les prises de
paroles qu'il a pu avoir après que
donald trump a annoncé qu' il n'y avait
pas la signature de l'accord de paris en
tout cas que les ministres retirer que
le fait d'adopter à chaque fois même
vestimentairement le même costume que
les personnes qu'elle a rencontrées a
effectivement troubler une partie assez
important d'être au samedi a également
une deuxième aspect c'est le moment où
il ya eu à la confrontation isf d'un
côté appel de l'autre avec
l'interrogation toujours de comment
comment reconnaît-on comment fait-on qui
puisse y avoir différents systèmes de
solidarité qui peuvent qui peuvent
exister
quoi qu'il en soit aujourd'hui ce qui
est intéressant c'est que certes
emmanuel macron n'a réuni que 24% des
voix au premier tour
certes il ya eu un taux d'abstention
record au premier tour comme au deuxième
tour des élections initiative il n'est
pas suspect d'un terme il n'est pas
suspect de trahison et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que quand vous
interrogez les français vont nous dire
on n'est pas forcément d'accord avec la
politique est menée il ya des points qui
nous pose véritablement question mais
dans un même élan on a le sentiment que
globalement c'était un peu la promesse
présidentielle qui était portée et pour
une fois qu'un président tient ses
promesses
jusqu'à présent ça t'es pas dû attendre
comme mais jusqu'à présent on lui
accorde au moins le crédit d'avoir tenu
une partie de ses engagements mais le
fait qu'ils soient sur un nuage c'est un
peu normal de dire il a eu toutes les
chances du monde pour arriver là où il
est
lyon a pris sa penderie sur la tête etc
etc je veux dire et c'est normal les
autres présidents ses prédécesseurs des
gens comme mitterrand avait eu plusieurs
échecs jacques chirac avait eu plusieurs
échecs peut-être seulement giscard
d'estaing d'ailleurs ça lui a coûté cher
n'avait pas connu déchets coupable et
c'est normal qu'ils soient dans cet état
là fondez vous rendez pas compte on
aurait dû plus prendre un ticket du loto
avec lui on est millionnaire
alors est-ce qu'il faut prendre un
ticket du loto et carlès fij demande
c'est la question à je ne sais pas
combien d'euros ce soir mais redit on va
à bruxelles puisque c'est là que se
trouve le président destitué de la
généralité de catalogne en tous les cas
c'est une info nos confrères espagnols
d'el periodico
alors le président de la généralité de
catalogne cette île réfugiés dans la
capitale belge cherche t'il une solution
en tout cas il se tourne
il a l'air de se tourner vers l'europe
alors avant de revenir sur cette étape
européenne voudrait une question une
réponse rapide celle du figaro.fr
d'ailleurs est ce que les uns les autres
la crise en catalogne
vous inquiète alexandre vecchio oui
parce que je pense que ça va déterminer
notre futur je pense que ce qu'il y à
hautcoeur de la crise en catalogne c'est
justement toujours cette question de la
mondialisation est ce qu'on va vers plus
d'ouverture et de mondialisation mais ça
va se traduire aussi par des formes de
repli identitaire et de morcellement où
est ce qu'on va d'un retour des états
nations et c'est la question qui se pose
en espagne je crois que rajoy en tapant
du poing sur la table à susciter le
retour d'une forme de patriotisme
espagnol fois ça plutôt d'un bon oeil et
donc il ya ce duel entre une europe hors
sol purement économique tournée vers le
monde et le retour de ce qui m'apparaît
comme l'échelle indispensable de la
démocratie c'est-à-dire l'état nation
abbas s'est pas tellement la vie on
pensait que cet avis était vraiment
partagé même dans la classe politique
française alexandre depuis depuis la
crise catalan est même encore ce
week-end et ben on s'est lourdement
trompé bon jean luc mélenchon demande un
référendum mais la critique la plus
virulente et contre la maladie de
l'identité catalane
elle est venue d'un rocardien d'un
regard des 1 comme manuel valls mais
celui ci s'appelle jean paul jean paul
huchon et qui a été extrêmement virulent
contre le gouvernement espagnol est pour
lui le sens de l'histoire et ailleurs on
les coûte au moins que j'ai compris
durant ces quinze jours l'europe
ce sera l'europe des régions et c'est
normal que les gens s'attachent de plus
en plus à la région puisque la
mondialisation impose un sp d'ordre
mondial
donc on se rapproche de sa vérité de son
identité et fait donc l'europe des
régions finira par triompher gelé
toujours pas en paix l'europe des
régions finira par triompher je les ai
toujours pensé c'est ce qu'a déclaré
jean paul huchon qui est pas si
rocardien qui ça nous expliquera
peut-être jean daniel lévy mais il y a
en tout cas cette déclaration qu'il a
faite hier soir sur france info ne
pouvait faire que le bonheur du très
souverainiste florian philippot ce matin
toujours sur france info dont le coot
embêté par cette affaire mais elle a
quand même joué avec le feu en
encourageant les régionalismes en par
ces politiques d'austérité en aggravant
les inégalités entre territoires en
créant le comité des régions en incitant
aux eurorégion des deux côtés des
frontières
elle a joué avec le feu alors
aujourd'hui évidemment elle préfère
avoir un gros un état espagnol un peu
servile de toute façon puisque l'état
espagnol nom n'a jamais remis en cause
une solution n'ayant européenne à une
alacatel il semble qu est ce que c'est
vous qui avez soufflé ses déclarations
non mais je suis assez d'accord est ce
que fait jean paul huchon finalement est
pas mal parce qu'il n'est pas hypocrite
au mans il dit la vérité c'est à dire
qu'effectivement depuis des années
l'europe a favorisé les régions pour
affaiblir les états nations aujourd'hui
ça a créé une forme de cac de cas où est
donc l'européen un peu en panique
vis-à-vis de ce qu'elle a elle même
déclenché mais mais oui moi ce que
j'espère c'est que de la crise va naître
une forme de raison qu'on va
s'apercevoir que l'état nation c'est pas
si mal
anne vous avez relativiser je vous
entendu dans le creux grandes oreilles
enfin je pense que c'est sa vérité parce
qu'ils lui il al air d
il semblait approuver cette cette
évolution vers une europe des régions
mais où je suis d'accord avec alexandre
c'est sur cette analyse qu'effectivement
l'europe a favorisé le fait qu'on avait
l'impression qu'il ya un échelon qu'il
y'avait l'europe les régions et entre
les deux que le effectivement la nation
avait disparu que ça posait un problème
ça et donc ce qui est inquiétant dans ce
qui se passe actuellement c'est que
c'est peut-être un une possible
contagion ou quoi dans d'autres d'autres
pays d'autres réveil identitaire donc
qu'il est à lisbourg m en italie qui
pourrait menacer aussi d'autres d'état
nation et ça en saas et c'est un peu
inquiétant est d'ailleurs précision car
les scuds demande est à bruxelles
en fait à la rencontre aux dernières
nouvelles des dirigeants
indépendantistes flamands
laniel l'europe à jouer au pompier
pyromane dans cette affaire je sais pas
nager entendu jean paul huchon là moi je
fais attention à jean paul huchon
puisque depuis qui nous a fait perdre
les jeux olympiques de londres
c'était en 2012 à singapour j'ai pas
tellement confiance en lui il avait fait
un discours minable mais c'est pas ça le
problème
non le problème le problème si je te dis
très tendue dans l'ex qu'est ce qui dans
les couloirs de france thalys va signer
ce qui me fascine moi c'est que
aujourd'hui encore l'obstination d'un
homme politique peut changer le cours de
l'histoire
puis de mon île à il est obstiné il peut
changer et vous savez à quoi ça me fait
non pas du tout mais je comprends mieux
pourquoi certains personnages et leur
obstination ont fait changer le cours de
l'histoire moi ça ils soient rapidement
ça me fait penser à la dépêche dems qui
provoquent la guerre demi de 1870 je
sais pas pourquoi non mais c'est vrai il
ya quelque chose comme ça c'est à dire
il ya des intérêts économiques
normalement devrait être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus en phase avec une
discussion et c'est eric ça et
l'obstination de quelqu'un peut arriver
je sais pas si ce serait un drame
le fait que la catalogne soit
indépendante mais encore l'obstination
et la puissance d'un homme par rapport à
un événement politique alors que toutes
ces dernières années on nous fait
comprendre qu aujourd'hui dans un monde
globalisé etc
les hommes politiques n'ont plus
d'importance là en l'occurrence il a son
importance même si on reprend quelques
années au préalable en 2006 les
premières enquêtes qui ont été réalisés
justement pour savoir si les habitants
la catalogne étaient favorables à
l'indépendance de la catalogne sa réunis
c'est uniquement 10 % des habitants
quelques années plus tard en 2014 on
avait une personne sur deux qui étaient
favorables à l'indépendance de la
catalogne donc plus 40 points en huit
ans c'est un mouvement qui est un
mouvement qui est extrêmement rapide et
qui montre bien qu'on n'est pas que sur
des rapports que des rapports à
caractère économique mais qui a une
dimension identitaire extrêmement forte
qui se nourrit effectivement d'un
préalable et d'un rapport est un rapport
extrêmement ancien quart monde quasiment
s'il ne trompent pas au début du 16e
siècle sur le rapport entre la catalogne
et l'espagne donc pas la double déjà à
ce moment là il y avait des détentions
et qu'elles ont ré émerger notamment
parce que le il ya des acteurs qui ont
réussi à leur donner un sens face à un
sentiment qui était un sentiment
d'interrogations sur cet aspect identité
à aix il ya un poids de l'europe
aujourd'hui qui pèse qui pèsent au
niveau des régions mais également au
niveau des différents peuples européens
c'est quel avenir en commun
on se construit quelle est la
perspective qui est donné à l'ensemble
des peuples européens qui constitue une
point d'interrogation qui ne fait qu a
pas d'identité européenne qui est
suffisamment forte aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir réunir les différents peuples et
qui font qu'on va se reconstruire ici ou
là chacun a sa propre identité avec les
conséquences qu'on peut croire vraiment
elle aussi il ya la dimension
identitaire mais ce qui me frappe en
catalogne mais aussi en italie c'est
qu'on est aussi en pleine révolte des
élites puisque c'est la volonté
d'indépendance il ya des raisons
identitaires mais il ya aussi des
raisons économiques et en l'occurrence
c'est le riche qui choisissent de faire
sécession avec le reste de la population
souvient qu'après le break si certains
proposent l indépendance de londres moi
quand je vois la politique dame hidalgo
je me demande si elle veut pas que paris
devienne une île au milieu de la france
donc il ya ya's out
vous ferez une transition toute trouvée
juste une réponse à la question de
marion concrètement où on est on dans ce
rapport de force madrid catalogne
finira-t-elle indépendante et ben j'en
avais les gens daniel levy vient de
donner une élément de réponse
et puis il ya le live sur le site
internet du figaro qui suit minute par
minute la situation en catalogne et vous
pouvez vous y reporter on revient en
france à la cinémathèque où il ya une
manifestation ce soir en cause la venue
du cinéaste roman polanski pour une
rétrospective consacrée à son oeuvre
alors en pleine campagne balances ton
port et après des rassemblements ce
week-end en france contre le harcèlement
il viole le collectif féministe contre
le cyber-harcèlement s'indigne on écoute
sa secrétaire général c'est pas tant la
rétrospective que son invitation
l'invitation du réalisateur
franco-polonais à l'inauguration
c'est à dire qu'on pourrait ne pas lui
rendre hommage ne pas lui dérouler le
tapis rouge ça serait je pense la
moindre des choses je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour qu'on continue à regarder
les films de roman polanski
sans être obligé par ailleurs de le voir
parader un peu partout à la télé à
l'académie des beaux-arts
on peut séparer l'homme de l'oeuvre
faisons le arrêtons de l'invité arrêtons
de lui dérouler le tapis rouge
vingt-six mille personnes ont déjà signé
la pétition refusant le mage à polanski
alexandre vous avez la signer non parce
que je suis pas pour la démocratie de la
pétition mais pour une fois je trouve
que le discours était relativement
modérée moi je ne suis pas pour qu'on
interdise l'oeuvre de paul en skiff
parce qu'il faut juger l'oeuvre plutôt
que l'homme est donc là c'est le
collectif
c'est même à ça qu'on va plaindre
l'animation de notre effectif dense on
est dans son rôle si de diffuser
l'oeuvre par contre effectivement n'est
pas obligé de dérouler le tapis rouge à
polanski mais je suis contre
l'interdiction d'une de la rétrospective
parce qu'il a une oeuvre qui méritent
d'être analysées célébrer la
cinémathèque est dans son rôle d'autant
plus que ça avait été lancée avant avant
toutes ces polémiques là oui je suis un
peu mal à l'aise avec le climat actuel
c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression qu'on
a tellement ouvert les vannes convient
de racisme qu'on est entouré que de
pervers d'obsédé sexuel évidemment il y
en a mais mais il ya un moment où trop
c'est trop on va tomber dans une espèce
d'ordre moral exacerbée voire de climat
presque de maccarthysme alors évidemment
c'est répréhensible je vais je vais pas
dire que je sais que les les faits qui
sont enfin les qui sont reprochés à
roman polanski sont sont graves
il s'agissait d'une gamine de 13 ans il
faut aussi peut-être resituer dans le
contexte de l'époque
ces relations sexuelles illégales et non
consentie avec une mineure il n'y a pas
de poursuite de la victime née de la
famille mais du procureur en charge de
l'enquêté
extradition c'était après les années de
ceinture c'est comme lorsqu'on on
ressort les trucs sur cohn bendit s'est
écrit après 68 sur la pédophilie alors
c'est comment dire je condamne c'est
répréhensible et mais je trouve que ce
déferlement devient écoeurant et que
j'ai peur que ça devienne
contre-productif en fait c'est ce que je
crains alors je repose la question c'est
que il ya par exemple dans le figaro il
ya eu deux tribunes qui ont été signé ce
matin une notamment de la sexologue
thérèse argot et qui dit cette phrase
mon inquiétude face au devenir au
devenir de la génération porno mauveaux
le titre de puritaine par les inrocks
les inrocks et elle dénonce au passage
la une des inrocks qui ai fait le café
le mag magazine sur bertrand cantat
condamné il ya quatorze ans pour le
meurtre de sa compagne marie trintignant
est ce qu'il n'ya pas si je vous suis
s'il n'y a pas de la schizophrénie sans
parler d'hypocrisie un peu dans cette
campagne dans la campagne dans la
campagne actuelle contre polanski ou
contenant le plus générale ce qui est ce
qui est embêtant mais on l'a déjà dit
c'est l'impression que ça ouvre la porte
à la délation quoi c'est à dire à un
déversement serre qu'il faut dénoncer
des faits qui sont répréhensibles et
mais il faut que ça soit quand c'est des
faits avérés que qui est effectivement
des poursuites réel et que en fait c'est
des choses dans la vie tous les jours
qu'il faut changer c'est par exemple le
comportement quand une femme va au
commissariat pour porter plainte et
qu'on lui reconnaît c'est des choses
comme ça qui doivent bouger ce
déferlement sur sur les réseaux sociaux
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai enfin ça
peut être une vertu libératoire mais
est-ce que ça c'est vraiment efficace et
bon c'est ça sert qu'il faudrait que ça
soit vraiment suivi d'actes efficace
c'est à dire qu'effectivement camp quand
une femme dans une entreprise dans dont
la rue n'importe où est agressée
sexuellement qu'elle puisse être
reçus convenablement lorsqu'elle va
déposer plainte est prise au sérieux oui
ça ça fait partie des choses importantes
je pense que c'est là dessus qu'il
faudrait que ça bouge mais tout ce
déversement j'ai payé un moment où aussi
un peu trop d'années bilalian sur l'
affaire polanski
oui c'est vrai qu'on a on a le sentiment
que à un moment donné ça devient un tout
petit peu trop parce que moi j'ai vécu
aux états unis aux etats unis
aujourd'hui les relations dans dans les
bureaux c'est vous monter dans
l'ascenseur
s'il ya une femme ou regarder
précisément les numéros des étages et le
nom de la compagnie d'ascenseurs pour
pas être accusée d'avoir harcelé la
jeune femme
quand vous la recevez dans votre bureau
vous laisser la porte ouverte parce que
au cas où elle viendrait se plaint voilà
la société américaine aujourd'hui moi je
voudrais répondre à côté de la plaque
moi ce que je ne comprends pas dans ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est pourquoi
les femmes ne s'attaque pas non plus à
d'autres femmes comme kardashian zahia
des femmes krivine
c'est le gâteau ce qui m'intéresse
hardos maintenant de se promener tout nu
ou presque
ou bien encore sur les chaînes de la tnt
ses émissions ou été comme hiver en
étant suivent d'abord de dire oui ça
revient après ça oui m'enfin on peut
s'interroger
elle dénonce pas ça c'est à ces
occasions féministe et ces femmes là
concours à la situation dont on parle
aujourd'hui en plus il ya un grand il ya
un grand vide non là dans les
associations aussi qui pousse à ça oui
mais dans les aciers féministe aussi
j'en entends pas parler du problème des
femmes et de l'islam c'est pas
obligatoirement ces femmes là qui sont
agressés sur l' affaire polanski
bah moi je moi je trouve que c'est un
petit peu exagéré je veux dire on est en
train de célébrer son sont passés de
deux cinéastes et je crois que ça a été
décidé avant effectivement est bon ce
qu'il a fait non pas déroulé le tapis
rouge où il y avait une soirée ce soir
où on parle entre cinéastes entre
spécialistes du cinéma de ce qu'il a
fait très bien
moi je trouve que c'est un tout petit
peu exagéré
jean daniel lévy dans l'opinion commence
à comment évolue le client part
peut-être d'abord à le faire pendant ce
qui était peut-être surtout généralement
sur cette place à la croissance n'avait
pas de travail et j'ai pas vu de
sondages là dessus ma réponse va être
assez rapide on voit bien la tension qui
existe même temps on voit que les films
de polanski continuer à être visionnés
ou louer de la part des français donc il
n'y a pas forcément cette forme de
séparation entre l'homme et la femme en
seconde lecture et d'autres moments même
si c'est sur des registres qui sont du
registre complètement différent où la
question de la morale d'un point de vue
global avait été abordée on peut penser
nous fait du départ de gérard depardieu
qui avaient copieusement insulté les
français on s'est demandé ce que la
carte jardin paru sera terminé on a vu
que ça n'a jamais été le cas donc à des
mots en fête où il ya une séparation
même si je passe évidemment pas eu tout
ce même registre en tout cas un regard
personnel et un regard sur eux sur le
banc en tant que tel c'est intéressant
malgré tout c'est que quand vous
interrogez les français depuis de
nombreuses années ils vous disent il ya
quand même un problème d'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes en matière de
reconnaissance globalement il y avait
également la perception de manière
diffuse que les relations dans le cadre
de l'entreprise dans le cadre des des
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
n'étaient pas tout à fait équilibré et
que le harcèlement existait et qu'il
avait tendance à exister et qui
n'étaient pas forcément mis sur la place
publique
puisqu'à présent ne se passait rien et
souvent la france avance non pas quand
ya un consensus mais lorsqu'une crise
est peut-être que cette situation de
crise permettra de déboucher sur une
situation qui seront ciation que d'après
ses quotas mot sur la situation globale
plus que sur polanski ce qui est
surprenant dans toute cette affaire
c'est qu'on dirait qu'il ya quand même
un deux poids deux mesures rien
effectivement des violences faites aux
femmes qui semblent tolérer un petit peu
pour polanski je pense à bertrand cantat
qui ont une des inrockuptibles et de
l'autre effectivement d'autres qui ne
sont pas dénoncés je pense à la violence
faite aux femmes en banlieue au lien
avec l'islam
oka tariq ramadan jeu
je m'étonne par exemple que mediapart
qui est quand même regretter les pros
les premiers en pointe sur balances ton
port qui est son spécialiste de faire
des listes et des enquêtes qui ont
attaqué jean lassalle très fortement la
restée étrangement silencieux du coup
c'est ça qui est jeune dans cette
affaire c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'il
ya des boucs émissaires commodes et
d'autres qui ne serait pas criminel et
des femmes qui seraient victimes et
d'autres qui ne serait pas victime en
fonction de leur origine sociale et
ethnique
et ça c'est vraiment problématique et
l'autre info tchoyi keynes et call in
space et héros de la série house of
cards qui se retrouve dans la tourmente
il est accusé d'avoir harcelé l'acteur
anthony rapp alors âgée de 14 ans il a
fait ses excuses
restez avec nous dans un instant focus
sur une tout autre actualité c'est
l'histoire c'est la révolution d'octobre
et l'anniversaire le centenaire à
l'occasion donc de ce centenaire de la
prise du palais d'hiver de leningrad
retour avec ariane le coeur et geoffroy
cahier sur lequel lénine son ascension
et ses crimes
on se retrouve demain avec cette fois-ci
marie amélie lombard a très vite sur
filet en live
[Musique]
à